for nearly three months 55 year-old
Rosario Aaron era has been going out
every day looking for a job she joins
the queue at this employment agency
hoping like the rest to secure work as a
housemaid a job that used to be easy to
find but no longer nothing go I'm about
on the wane if I don't work I can't pay
for my rent my bills my food without a
salary how can I survive for me it's
essential the director of the agency
says the number of Chileans looking for
work is skyrocketing in Pinole in Lima
Samana
last week I was at an employment fair
before 85% of candidates were immigrants
now it's 5050 that means that a lot more
people are looking for this kind of work
for the first time so we were trying to
train in places the sharp rise in
unemployment is just one of the direct
consequences of the escalating trade
dispute between the US and China the
price of copper Chile's main export has
fallen 17 percent this year the value of
the Chilean Bissel regarded as one of
the most stable in Latin America has
dropped to its lowest level in more than
three years making imports more
expensive Chile's export-based economy
is particularly vulnerable to what
economists call external shock so what
affects its main trading partner China
has a direct impact our exports have
been going down this year beyond the
effect of copper price very worrying
pace so clearly the fact of what has
been known more impacted by this crisis
and the people that you see here tens of
thousands of migrants have come here to
Chile just this year alone the majority
of them from Venezuela and they're here
at the Immigration Department hoping to
get their papers in order so that they
can get jobs that are becoming harder
and harder to come by
the economy Minister tells aljazeera
that he remains cautiously optimistic
the macroeconomic and financial
fortitude of our economy will allow us
to confront this adverse situation but
for how long is the question especially
for people like Rosario Araneta who
cannot afford to wait for the trade war
to end you see a human al Jazeera
Santiago